-We are back hanging out with Noah Schnapp right now.
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah, we -- we love you.
We are about to play "Hey Robot."
Here we go.
-♪ Hey, Hey, Hey Robot ♪
♪ Hey Robot ♪ -Done this before?
-Now, this -- We've never done this before.
-Oh. -No. Yeah.
But this -- Here's how it works.
It's based on a real board game.
Okay? This -- It's called "Hey Robot."
You can play at home. It's like the classic game
Password, but your partner is a smart speaker.
Okay? So now here's the deal.
So first I -- Don't look. Don't hint.
Don't -- Don't spoil it for your own self.
Stop spoiling.
First, I will pick a card with a word on it.
Then we'll talk turns asking a question to get the speaker
to somehow say that word somewhere in its answer.
-Okay. -If it does, you get a point.
-Okay. -Okay? It seems easy.
-Okay. -Alright.
And maybe I'll prove that it is easy.
Okay, here we go. -Wait. You're going first?
-Here's my word. I'll go first. This is my word.
-Okay. -Okay.
Uh...
Alexa, who sings "Fun, Fun, Fun"?
-Alexa: Mike Love's sang in "Fun, Fun, Fun"
by the Beach Boys.
-Yes, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're so good.
-That was actually -- -Oh, my God.
I'm gonna be so bad at this.
-"Mike Love sang in 'Fun. Fun. Fun-Fun. Fun. Fun.'"
Alright. Now you get to -- -Do I get to go first?
-Yeah, now you get -- You can do it.
And I don't even know why we're face-down.
You can show it to everybody.
-Gosh. Geez. -Sorry about that.
-What?! This is so much harder!
-I disagree.
-Badminton? -Badminton?
-What?! -Beach, badminton.
They both start with a "B." It's fun. Summertime, man.
-Okay. Oh, my God.
-You have to ask. You have to say the name.
-Okay, yeah. I just need --
Alexa, what is the tennis game
that's not --
-Alexa: Which game do you want?
-Oh. Alexa, what is the sport with a racket and a...
-Audience: Birdie! -...a birdie?
-Alexa: This might answer your question.
According to dreammoods.com...
-No! Alexa, Alexa, Alexa! What's the game with a birdie?
-According to an Alexa Answers contributor,
GamePigeon features multiplayer games
you can play with your friends and family via...
-Okay. I got a hard word.
-Alexa: Does that answer your question?
-No. Alright. Now it's my turn.
-Alexa: Thanks for your feedback.
-You're welcome.
That was a little passive-aggressive.
-Yeah, Alexa.
-"Thank you so much for your feedback.
Really appreciate it."
Alright. Let me think. Uh. Uh. Alright, ready?
Alexa, what sport do you play with a shutt-- Sorry.
Alexa, what sport do you play with a shuttlecock?
-Oh!
-Alexa: Here's something I found on the Web.
According to kidsearch.com,
a shuttlecock is used in the sport badminton.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so unfair. You were ready for this.
-That's the way to do it. -There's no way...
-You walk like you're gonna go down.
Then you get...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I got -- I'm gonna get the next one.
-And then -- Alright. Go ahead. It's your turn.
You got this. Here we go.
-Oh, I can do this one. -You can?
-Upside Down.
-Alright. Alright.
-Okay. -Alright...
-Should I use "Stranger Things"?
-No! -Or can I --
-"Nah!"
"Yah!"
[ Laughter ]
-Alexa, what is the opposite of right-side up?
-Alexa: Here is an answer from an Alexa Answers contributor
that I translated.
The opposite of left is right.
-What?! No, let me go again. Let me go again.
Alexa, Alexa. [ Buzzer ]
What -- What is the alternate dimension in "Stranger Things"?
-Alexa: Here's something I found on the Web.
-Oh, my God. I hate this stupid thing.
-According to chicagotribune.com,
in the 1980s-set "Stranger Things,"
which premiered in 2016,
Will Byers, Noah Schnapp,
is abducted by a creature called the Demogorgon
and taken into an alternate dimension called
the Upside Down.
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo! Come on!
-Yo! That was good.
-That's my man right there. -Oh, my God.
-Noah Schnapp, everybody. "Stranger Things."
Volume one of season four is streaming now on Netflix.
Volume two premieres July 1st. -I hate this thing!
-We'll be right back with music from 070 Shake.
Stick around, everybody.